maintenant madame Sonia de la pauvreté
pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission spéciale monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je tiens
avant toute chose à saluer le travail de
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur élément de la Commission
spéciale sur cette proposition de loi
qui a surtout cherché à rendre le 0
artificialisation nette le fameux âne
acceptable par tous les territoires
cette PPL porte l'équité au-delà des
dogmatismes avec réalisme et pragmatisme
si la sobriété foncière est un objectif
nécessaire pour affronter le défi de
l'urgence climatique sa mise en oeuvre
nécessite un travail sur le terrain où
chaque voie de chaque territoire doit
être entendu chaque discussion rendue
possible et être le résultat de la prise
en compte des solidarités territoriales
cette PPL favorise donc le dialogue
territorial renforçant la gouvernance
décentralisée elle accompagne les
projets structurants de demain prend
mieux en compte les spécificités des
territoires et prévoit les outils
techniques et réglementaires
facilitateurs l'équité par la solidarité
territoriale consenti discuter entre
tous c'est la clé de la réussite de
l'objectif de la sobriété foncière dans
l'article de la loi climat et résilience
portant sur Lausanne reviennent souvent
les termes déclinés et déclinaisons la
logique est bien centrale et descendante
pour les élus de terrain que nous sommes
où avons été ou pour ceux au nom
desquels nous nous exprimons nous savons
que ce que ce que la loi décline l'état
l'impose les quelques décrets déjà trop
vite parus en sont la parfaite
illustration or l'application du zan à
l'ensemble du territoire et des
politiques publiques conduit les élus
locaux à subir des injonctions
contradictoires permanentes c'est
Lausanne plus garantir l'accès aux
services publics et par un public
essentiels plus assurer notre survêter
industrielle alimentaire et sanitaire
plus obéir aux obligations en matière de
logement social plus permettent le
maintien des espaces publics et le
développement indispensable à la qualité
vie ou encore par exemple favoriser la
biodiversité au travers des trames
vertes chacun de ces objectifs traîne
son cortège de de contraintes toute
prioritaire il devient impossible d'y
répondre systématiquement face à la
technicité de ces injonctions
contradictoires à la multiplicité des
acteurs les élus locaux ne peuvent
qu'être désemparés il est donc urgent de
leur donner les voies et moyens qui
aident à l'arbitrage au choix et
simplifie leur tâche ainsi l'objectif de
nos travaux et des amendements que
portera le groupe Union centrices sont
de permettre que la mise en oeuvre
d'usage se fasse par un consensus
territorial garant d'équité et
d'équilibre rural urbain pour cela la
proposition de loi favorise d'abord le
dialogue territorial autour du zan et
renforce l'association des collectivités
qui décident ensemble et échangent avec
l'État sur les objectifs pour cela aussi
la proposition de loi répartie les
consommations foncières en fonction des
responsabilités responsabilités et de la
réalité des besoins pour cela encore la
proposition de loi prend mieux en compte
les spécificités territoriales notamment
les territoires ruraux ruraux se frappé
par l'érosion côtière montagneux car le
zan ici est aussi et surtout une affaire
de différenciation pour cela également
la proposition de loi vise à prévoir les
outils locaux à la main des
collectivités pour faciliter la
transition vers le zal notre groupe
proposera ainsi de consolider la chaîne
maillet de l'ingénierie territoriale sur
la sobriété foncière renforçant les
outils locaux d'observation de mesures
de planification opérationnelle et de
gestion foncière pour cela enfin cette
PPL
appuie sur les besoins en matière de
maîtrise et de recalification des
friches véritable décennies gratuites
d'artificialisation dans le congzane
mais terriblement coûteuse et complexe à
utiliser
vous l'avez compris monsieur le ministre
cette proposition de loi c'est la mise
en oeuvre plus démocratique et concertée
partout et partout d'un objectif certes
louable mais qui s'impose et qui ont
l'état de la loi oppose et divise car le
zan ne peut ne doit pas aggraver les
fractures territoriales déjà si présente
dans notre pays terreau des refuges et
des colères le groupe Union centriste
votera ainsi en faveur de cette
proposition de loi en attendant bien sûr
un second volet qui portera sur les
outils fiscaux et financiers du zan je
vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
la